[Musique]
maman je suis qui un tommy du ciel
nous sommes sûrs que tu n'es pas venu
ici par hasard
[Musique]
c'est que c'est pas facile pourtant sont
différentes des camarades
meiway inquiète et ratera jim webb le
nom et les gouttes et bleu
[Musique]
ce que tu fais je veux qu'on meneur des
collants ferme et sa vraie mère vous
savez seulement qui sait c'est moi sa
vraie mère on s'en va
il ya peut-être un truc qui va pas je
suis brandon je ne ferai jamais rien
outre notre avis c'est pas notre fils
qui se fiche de moi là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et un problème est ce que votre fils
serait là
c'est la seule personne à savoir à quel
point je suis spécial il n'y aurait
aucun survivant sur les 268 passagers
qui étaient à bord
[Musique]
non
non non
or ce que tu as fait je sais qu'il y ait
eu beaucoup
toi
[Musique]
daury
je vais faire le bien maman je t'assure
[Musique]